three-two-one
yeah it sounds terrible I'm amazed at
how much control I have we're almost
drifting
[Applause]
[Music]
I was like oh my goodness I hope we
don't crash
[Applause]
here we go when I was driving the rug
was a little bumpy but the tires held up
pretty well Wow I think evenings flying
all the way off
[Applause]
as far as Adam driving those are
definitely extreme conditions
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think I can feel some specific issues
and that is why we can't have nice
things
[Music]
despite Adams inevitable need to push
the duct tape tires beyond even their
prodigious capabilities the results
clear cotton after Adams ride
the tires were trashed but if I got a
flat and I had a whole bunch of rolls of
duct tape in my trunk and a lot of time
I think I could definitely make a tire
Adam this tires gone absolutely gone you
destroy these things I did look at the
one over here this one's also seen
better days including this morning
overall I'm really surprised of how good
these duct-tape tires actually held up
in the great duct-tape Mythbusters
tradition can you build a duct-tape
tired there's no doubt in my mind that
you can its cannon a better driver than
Adam that's plausible so should we call
it the myth that duct tape could make a
viable tire in a pinch yes I feel like
it's totally confirmed confirmed
absolutely good burn